here's something that did bother me and
I'm glad the NFL has finally figured it
out and that this really is good news
and I don't sense that people understand
it the way they should so let's go ahead
and try to explain it as best we can you
know in the aftermath of that Rams
Saints debacle in the NFC Championship
game something had to happen a safety
net had to be put in place to prevent a
situation like what we saw where there
was a blatant pass interference that was
committed but not called and there's no
one in a position to fix it when it
happens because it's not subject to
replay review so the NFL after I think
Big Cat it took a couple of months
because I think that Rich McKay the
chairman of the competition committee
and others in the league wanted to just
treat this as a 100-year storm and it
happens and we'll just deal with that we
don't need to make major changes we can
tolerate the fact that it happens we're
all still going to continue to get
richer and richer people are still gonna
watch the games we don't need to make a
drastic move they tried that until it
was time for the league meetings in
Arizona they made the drastic move they
made all pass interference calls and Nan
calls offense and defensive subject to
replay review then they realized we went
too far and they spent the last three
weeks trying to carve it back here's the
end result and I think this is very good
news for the NFL replay review is
available for pass interference and
there will be automatic review in the
final two minutes and in overtime and
after touchdowns and turnovers you don't
have to rely on a coach's challenge that
we're gonna try to make it coach's
challenge only but here's the key that
person in the booth who presses the
button to activate automatic review at
the league office in New York the replay
official is gonna have a lot more power
over this and the standard for
initiating an automatic review is going
to be the same standard as overturning
the ruling on the field they're only
going to initiate an automatic review
when it is clear and obvious they're not
gonna slow it down
go frame by frame and try to figure out
whether or not there's justification for
a full review they're gonna see that it
is an egregious call or they're not
gonna activate automatic review that's
exactly what they need that's the fix
they need if you have that for ram
saints big cat you don't have that
controversy you are right and I've been
against this because I think it's gonna
slow the game down
and I think we do so many replays
already and this was a 100 year storm
but it looks like I lost that battle but
I agree with you that they're making
them the right move to at least meet
kind of people like me and my mindset
halfway in that we can't go back and
look at every single play as slow as
possible because it's the old saying
there's holding on every single play in
the NFL and if you want to find a
penalty you can find a penalty on almost
every single play and my fear always has
been not that we will have another
Saints Rams because that has happened
once or twice ever my fear has always
been that we will have a situation where
we slow the game down and take like what
the game really is guys running a
million miles an hour and completely
change it so as long as we're not doing
that I mean I have one question like now
is this replay review that's at any
point during the game a coach has what
one or how does that work
well well it's like any other play that
goes into that bucket of replay review
you've got to red flag challenges if you
get the first two right you get a third
when you always have to have a timeout
available in order to use the red flag
that's for all those periods when
automatic review isn't available see
what the league was trying to do they
wanted to have no automatic replay
review for pass interference they wanted
it in the final two minutes of either
half after a touchdown after a turnover
or in overtime to be in the exclusive
province of the coaches red challenge
flag because they didn't want to get in
a position where they are constantly
stopping the game for a replay review
because here's what the standard was to
initiate an automatic review and here's
what it is for everything but pass
interference if there isn't clear and
obvious evidence that the ruling on the
field was correct the replay official is
supposed to activate an automatic review
it's the mirror image of the standard to
overturn the ruling on the field so you
will return for clear and obvious
evidence of error you do an automatic
review if there isn't clear and obvious
evidence it was right well per pass
interference that is a huge range of
plays where hey we got to take a closer
look at this because there's hand
fighting there's incidental contact and
you could have you could have five
for those in the final two minutes of a
game where the replay official says well
you know what they they were pushing
they were shoving there was incidental
contact we better take a look at it so
they're making that bar as high as it is
as the bar for overturning the ruling on
the field so they won't be initiating
replay review over and over and over
again and they're only gonna do it when
there is that blatant shove that blatant
push that thing that causes you and I
Big Cat if we're watching the game to
say holy crap how did they miss that
okay so and I'm gonna play devil's
advocate here the only thing that makes
me nervous is you now have this
mechanism in place for the NFL to get it
right when it comes to pass interference
in late-game situations that feels like
it's going to be argued back and forth
and what you just described to me is all
well and good that we're not gonna
review every single play and we're not
gonna slow the game down to an absolute
crawl but now the blame is gonna go to
that guy in the booth who is pressing
that button because like I said fans are
gonna see pass interference on every
play and now that the option is there to
review it fans are gonna be yelling
hollering for that option on almost
every single play I'm just listen I'm
just a skeptic by Nature here and I just
I'm worried overall this isn't just NFL
this is all sports that we are getting
to a point where it's going to slow down
to such a crawl and every play is going
to be reviewed and when you do this to
to a point where you take away what the
refs are able to do and now they're
second-guessing themselves I'm just
nervous I think there is a line that you
can go too far trying to get it right
and I've said this to you Mike and I'll
say it again if I can't complain about
the refs they always say robot humps in
the MLB if I can't complain about the
UMP
that's like 50% of the conversations I
have with people on a day-to-day basis I
need to be able to as a fan say that my
team got screwed in a big situation and
not be able to review it and know
definitively that I am wrong and being
dumb you do have a good point here
though because there's going to be 17
different replay officials and replay
assistants who are
applying this standard and you may have
some who never press the button you may
have some who press the button too much
and it's going to come down to training
you're gonna have to make sure they
understand exactly when they should push
that button and there will be skeptic
concept-- ik cents Enix who think
there's going to be a pipeline from the
replay booth to the league office where
the league office says press the button
press the button I mean and and then
that's when they press the button yeah
think about the pressure on that think
about a Sunday night football game okay
think about the Chiefs and the Patriots
playing a Sunday Night Football game in
November and both teams are playing for
home-field advantage and there's under
two minutes and there's a deep pass
there's one person in the world who has
to sit there and decide whether we're
gonna review this that's crazy to me I
this is going to be an issue that we
talked about there are going to be times
when it gets when when we get it wrong
and that has been my concern from the
from the jump here Mike where I think I
have been right with my stance that we
got one egregiously wrong no one
disagrees no one thinks that it you know
it wasn't pass interference now what are
we gonna do we're gonna open Pandora's
box and now we're gonna get many many
calls wrong or in this case many many
times when the officials sitting up in
the booth either doesn't press the
button when they should or presses the
button when they shouldn't I look I
don't disagree with you because I still
want sky judge video official a member
of the crew who has the perspective that
we have at home who can communicate in
real-time with the referee the way
they've set that up that person in the
booth is going to be communicating in
real-time with the league office and
serving as the gatekeeper for replay
review I prefer a sky judge video
official and maybe that's what we get
next year
for now though they've taken what I
thought was going to be a complete
disaster and they've tried to engineer
it into something that may not be a
disaster and we'll just have to accept
that for this seat
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports